bevor wir anfangen schauen wir uns einen
auszug aus einer von putins letzten
reden an wir werden sie mit untertiteln
versehen damit ihr putin spekulation
voll wahrnehmen können
und
die frage die sich viele von euch jetzt
stellen werden von welchen vertretern
spricht tut ihm eigentlich nun in diesem
video werden wir es euch verraten ich
muss euch aber waren am ende des videos
wird es sehr ungemütlich werden böse
grauenvoll und sehr sehr hässlich nichts
für schwache nerven und liebe träume
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zum zeitpunkt der erstellung dieses
videos hatten fast vier millionen
ukrainische flüchtlinge das land
verlassen aber das wisst ihr ja schon
alles wahrscheinlich haben einige von
euch so wie auch wir sogar ukrainische
flüchtlinge bei sich zu hause
aufgenommen in unserem heutigen video
werden wir jedoch über den anderen
exodus sprechen denen dieser krieg
verursacht hat ja wir sprechen über den
exodus der russen tausende von russen
sind aus angst vor einem neuen eisernen
vorhang geflohen die ukrainische
flüchtlinge sind in europa herzlich
willkommen und das nicht nur aus
solidarität mit der ukraine erschrecken
auch wirtschaftliche interessen dahinter
[Musik]
polen zum beispiel nimmt mehr als eine
million ukraine auf in einer stadt die
warschau ist die einwohnerzahl in nur
wenigen wochen um 17 prozent gestiegen
im gegensatz zu früheren mit als wellen
haben es jedoch mit viel besser
ausgebildeten kulturell integrierbaren
und leistungsbereiten menschen zu tun
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie die
sozialkassen der aufnahmeländer länger
belasten werden dass nur mit eher gering
bei fast allen dieser flüchtlinge
handelt es sich um junge menschen
mehrheitlich frauen und kinder die
früher oder später einen job finden und
steuern zahlen werden und natürlich
rentenbeiträge ja so ist es wenn man es
genau nimmt verursacht diese
flüchtlingswelle weniger probleme in den
aufnahmeländern als im herkunftsland
enden dient diese arbeitskräfte und
beitragszahler dann fehlen werden wenn
der krieg jedoch gut für die ukraine
endet ist es nahe liegend das ziel
dieser ukraine zurückkehren werden um
ihr land wieder aufzubauen und das ist
wahrscheinlicher als bei den russen denn
seien wir ehrlich sie werden wohl so
schnell nicht mehr zurückkehren
wird der unterschied zwischen
ukrainischen flüchtlinge und russischen
migranten ist das letztere vor
repressionen und einem zunehmend
autoritären politischen system fliegen
das ist für russland ein fast genauso
großes problem wie die sanktionen mit
anderen worten russland verliert seine
besten arbeitskräfte informatiker
anwälte künstler und ärzte ein großer
teil der grauen zellen des landes
verlässt das land in atemberaubender
geschwindigkeit getrost dann sowieso
schon jahrzehnte unter einem
schleichenden brain brain so hat diese
nur in den turbogang geschaltet und im
wirtschaftsraum hat das ganze einen
namen verlust von humankapital was
allerdings ein großes problem für
russland darstellt ist eine riesen
chance zu den rest der welt denn all
diese talente müssen irgendwo hin und
glaubt mir ist etwas gibt wovon ein land
nie zu viel haben kann dann sind es
talentierte und fleißigen menschen und
hier kommt das eigentliche problem ins
spiel welches wir in unserem heutigen
video aufdecken wollen europas zögert
mit ihrer aufnahme und ihr werdet sagen
das war ja zu erwarten das muss doch
teil der sanktionen gegen russland sein
oder nun nichts dergleichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tatsächlich wäre die aufnahme große show
migranten im moment eine zusätzliche
bestrafung für russland wie sollen sie
eine konkurrenzfähige wirtschaft
aufbauen wenn ihre besten talente und
innovativsten unternehmer abgewandert
sind die frage des heutigen videos
lautet daher warum nimmt europa
russische einwanderer nicht mit offenen
armen auf gibt es vielleicht legitime
gründe dafür warum sollte es seine tore
so schnell wie möglich öffnen vor allem
wie sollte es dabei vorgehen was ist zum
8 damit keine fehler passieren heute
werden wir all diese fragen beantworten
aber zuerst lasst uns jedem land hessen
welches gerade die hölle auf erden
durchlebt um sich und europa vor den
horten des mörderischen tyrannen putin
zu verteidigen die zentralbank der
ukraine dem spenden aus der ganzen welt
an um den widerstand um ukrainische
streitet unterstützen und ich habe euch
den link zu ihrer spenden webseiten die
beschreibung gepackt so und nun zurück
zu unseren fragen bei deren beantwortung
holst die immer zunächst ein kurzer
blick in die geschichte weiterhelfen
wird
[Musik]
das neue alte russland
am 31 alle waren 1990 eröffnete
mcdonald's sein erstes restaurant auf
dem puschkin star platz in moskau mehr
als 6000 menschen standen an diesem tag
schlange um endlich mal einen bigmac
verspeisten zu können schon ziemlich
verrückt nicht wahr viele jahre lang war
mcdonald's in russland ein neuartiger
cooler ort an dem es völlig akzeptabel
war zu einem ersten date zu gehen
ursache des ganzen war aber keine
geschmacks verwirrung der russen sondern
die tatsache dass die marketing starke
fast-food-kette ganz einfach so als
symbol für das neue russland geworden
ist ein russland das sich dem westen
öffnete so und jetzt nach 32 jahren hat
mcdonald's russland wieder verlassen da
es sich um einen franchise unternehmen
handelt mussten alle restaurants weil
sie die goldenen bögen von mcdonald's
zieren ihren namen ändern
von nun an müssen die russen die in
happy meal wollen zu uncle war ja und
einige von euch werden sagen nun
wahrscheinlich ist es doch besser so für
die russen ist werden sie endlich
gesünder essen und ja ich glaube es gibt
leute die so etwas ohne einen funken
ironie oder doppeldeutigkeit sagen aber
falls jemand wirklich ernsthaft darüber
nachdenken sollte die antwort lautet
natürlich nein onkel wanja wird nach wie
vor triefende fritten und süchtig
machende kalorienbomben bürger verkaufen
die umfirmierung von mcdonald's in
russland ist nur ein symbolischer
verlust und daher nicht besonders
repräsentativ für die folgen die der
exodus praktisch aller multinationalen
unternehmen aus russland mit sich ziehen
wird denn nicht alle produkte und
dienstleistungen lassen sich so einfach
nachahmen die bürger
[Musik]
die russen werden keine ikea möbel
iphones und sarah t shirts verkaufen
können zumindest nicht direkt vor ort
über china usbekistan usw aber selbst
dann werden sehr viele von ihnen sehr
große probleme haben sich das alles noch
leisten zu können und in der
zwischenzeit zensiert putin weiterhin
websites und tausende von menschen
sitzen im gefängnis weil sie an anti
kriegs protesten teilgenommen haben
und auch die ohnehin nicht sehr hohe
kaufkraft der bevölkerung bricht gerade
ganz nach vorbild der russischen
konsultationen auf breiter front ein
aber das alles ist erst der anfang man
muss wirklich keinen
wirtschaftsnobelpreis im regal stehen
haben um vorhersagen zu können dass das
schlimmste noch vor sechs talente
fliehen aus russland da die westlichen
sanktionen greifen und ein paar leute
unter denen bestimmt keine regelmäßigen
die zuschauer sind werden sagen wo ist
das problem das ist doch gut für die
russen die da bleiben sie können sich
die wohnung der auswanderer günstig
schnappen und mehr gehalt auf der arbeit
verlangen aber so einfach ist das ganze
nicht stoppen langfristig handelt es
sich um eine volkswirtschaftliche
abwärtsspirale die eine bisher
untersucht wirkung entfalten wird die
wichtigste nachhaltige ressource eines
landes ist weder sein gas noch sein es
sind menschen die werte schaffen können
dies ist keine politisch korrekter
botschaft sondern schlicht und
ergreifend der realität um an kapital
ist für jede wirtschaft von
grundlegender bedeutung und wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt handelt es sich bei den
jetzigen auswanderer nicht gerade um den
intellektuellen bodensatz der russischen
gesellschaft
wir sprechen jedoch nicht nur von der
wissenschaft sondern auch von zwei
anderen bereichen die für die zukunft
russlands und auch für putins
imperialistische ambitionen entscheidend
sind die wissenschaft und die armee dass
jede armee nur ein spiegelbild ihrer
gesellschaft ist und langfristig nicht
leistungsfähiger als dieser sein kann
demonstriert die russische jahr auf
ihren ukraine feldzug durch das chaos
und ihren desaströsen grad an
korruptions organisation und
unproduktivität und diese missstände
werden sich nun noch weiter vertiefen
und die russische armee zur absoluten
lachnummer werden lassen vergleichbar
mit der eines drittwelt landes ebenso
dramatisch ist die kernschmelzen im
akademischen bereich da die russischen
hochschulen offiziell erklären mussten
putins spezialoperationen gutzuheißen
haben alle westlichen universitäten
forscher und wissenschaftler jegliche
zusammenarbeit mit ihnen beendet
russische forscher wenden sich nun
massenweise an ihre kollegen im ausland
damit sie ihnen bei der flucht helfen
aber selbst für die talentiertesten
unter ihnen ist es sehr schwierig
schnell eine stelle an westlichen
universitäten zu finden wieder einmal
steht die bürokratie im weg tatsächlich
leidet russland bereits 2010 unter einem
kontinuierlichen brain drain wir
sprechen von anwälten und buchhaltern
aber vor allem von meinen master
software digital universe den
informatikern denkt doch mal eine
sekunde darüber nach fast jedes goldene
zeitalter war dadurch gekennzeichnet
dass ist eine gruppe von menschen
geschafft hat etwas oder irgendwie
massiv auszuweiten dies können zb andere
menschen gewesen sein zum beispiel durch
was klar wo aber vor allem auch pflanzen
und tiere die rede ist von
landwirtschaft es finden mit der
dampfmaschine anderen gingen mit dem
verbrennungsmotor weiter sie verliehen
ihren meistern physische kräfte und
leistungsfähigkeit welcher der mensch
alleine nie und nimmer zu leisten
vermochte und heute haben wir eben die
silizium chips versklavt damit sie für
uns denken rechnen die welt für uns
ordnen organisieren und optimieren und
das auch in einem maße welches der
mensch alleine nicht zu leisten vermag
die meister und sklaventreiber unserer
silizium sklaven sind dabei die
informatiker und da das potenzial der
computer revolution noch lange nicht
ausgeschöpft ist sind mehr und bessere
informatiker gleichbedeutend mit mehr
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und wachstum tja
eigentlich hatte russland das zeug dazu
hier ganz vorne mit dabei zu sein denn
obwohl es noch nie ein technologie
paradies war war es aufgrund der
traditionellen ausrichtung seines
bildungssystems doch die heimat eine
ganze menge mathematisch gut
ausgebildeter menschen in einem land mit
über 140 millionen einwohnern gibt es
schließlich hunderttausende von talenten
deswegen war es nicht verwunderlich dass
viele von ihnen zu spezialisten für
cybersicherheit wurden erinnert ihr euch
noch an die videos in denen wir über
russische hacker berichtet haben all
diese leute könnten überall auf der welt
sehr gut bezahlte arbeit finden bisher
hielten sich jedoch in ihrem heimatland
auf der wendepunkt kam mit putins
invasion der ukraine
[Musik]
überlegt mal die größten multinationalen
konzerne sind erst weg und wir sprechen
nicht über burger flipper bei mcdonald's
märz 2022 verließen das land zum
beispiel die big four das sind die vier
größten
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften der
welt ihr wisst schon bei deloitte
pricewaterhousecoopers und kpmg allein
diese vier unternehmen beschäftigen mehr
als 15.000 spezialisten natürlich läutet
die tatsache dass diese marken gehen
nicht dass sie ihre beschäftigten
entlassen haben vergesst nicht dass
diese großen beratungsunternehmen als
partnerschafts unternehmen aufgebaut
sind so ein bisschen ähnlich wie
franchise unternehmen aller mcdonald's
mit anderen worten was früher die leute
russland hieß heißt es irgendwie anders
[Musik]
doch damit haben sie eine große zahl
ihrer kunden verloren dies bedeutet dass
die meisten mitarbeiter jetzt
vorübergehend beurlaubt sind wichtig für
neue projekte eingesetzt werden können
die frage ist ob sie wirklich in der
lage sein werden quasi über nacht neue
kunden zu finden nun
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht und das
bedeutet jeder raum dass tausende von
menschen arbeitslos werden menschen
jedoch leicht guten job in einem anderen
land finden könnten bevor die grenzen
geschlossen werden sie also ab und ja
ihr habt richtig gehört bevor russland
die grenzen schließt denn das risiko
dass russland sich nicht gehen lässt ist
ganz real in allen internetforen wird
sogar ein fohlen alle post und telekom
nachrichten zu löschen bevor man das
land verlässt warum weil die russische
polizei am flughafen verhöre durchführt
und jede nachricht die als antirussische
interpretiert werden kann eine ins
gefängnis bringen oder daran hindern
könnte das land zu verlassen gut aber wo
gehen eigentlich all die russen die das
land jetzt verlassen hin das werden wir
uns als nächstes ansehen
[Musik]
rette sich wer kann
ich gebe euch ist ein reales beispiel
obwohl ich keinen namen nennen kann um
niemanden zu gefährden es geht um ein
russisches unternehmen mit 500
mitarbeitern
es hat mehrere kunden in japan
theoretisch haben sie diese nicht
verloren dazu muss die firma einfach nur
russland verlassen was haben sie also
getan nun sie sind mit dem ganzen team
nach dubai gezogen um genau dubai hat
russland nicht funktioniert also hat der
geschäftsführer des russischen
unternehmens eine neue firma in dubai
gegründet und ist mit seinem gesamten
personal an umgezogen aber warte mal
denn dubai ist nicht der einzige ort an
dem es russen gibt wenn du ein millionär
oder ein spitzenprogramm ihrer bist du
bei natürlich ein sehr attraktives ziel
aber es ein problem es ist ein sehr sehr
teures pflaster was ist also mit den
rest der fachkräfte nun in den meisten
fällen ziehen sie an weniger attraktive
aber erschwinglichere viele länder wie
kasachstan indien oder georgien aber
innerhalb weniger wochen tausende von
russischen arbeitskräften aufgenommen
aber wer will schon nach kasachstan
gehen oder dort leben ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass niemand jemals
gesagt hat mein traum ist es in allen
marty zu leben aber denkt mal darüber
nach im moment ist es fast überall
besser als in putins russland
mehr als 25.000 menschen sind zum
beispiel nach georgien ausgereist unter
ihnen ist einer der besten bekanntesten
russischen youtuber novas der sogar
schon sein erstes video aus tiflis der
hauptstadt georgiens hochgeladen hat
allein im februar überquerten 44.000
großen die grenze nach finnland im
vormonat waren es noch weniger als
27.000
[Musik]
und hier kommen wir zu jedem großen
problem dass wir in diesem video
aufdecken wollen was passiert eigentlich
mit all den russen die zum beispiel in
finnland das heißt der europäischen
union ankommen können sie überhaupt
einen job finden können sie eine wohnung
kaufen können sie sich in europa
integrieren nun die antwort darauf ist
nein so sieht's aus europa nimmt russen
als touristen auf das heißt mit einem
visum das es ihnen erlaubt ein paar
monate zu bleiben aber nicht zu arbeiten
und einige sagen vielleicht bravo was
für eine kluge entscheidung die fünfte
kolonne passiert schon groß genug aber
das ist ziemlich herunter wir später
sehen werden gefährlicher quatsch die
meisten dieser menschen kommen hierher
eben weil sie vom system putin die
schnauze voll haben sie kommen zu uns
weil sie unsere werte leben wollen nicht
sein und fakt ist europa braucht kluge
junge einwanderer die arbeiten und in
die rentenkassen einzahlen wollen und
die unsere werte teilen nicht ablehnen
versteht ihr was ich meine europa hat
zwei gigantische probleme die renten
krise und den mangel an arbeitskräften
und klar in manchen ländern wie spanien
ist es eine beleidigung zu sagen dass es
einen arbeitskräftemangel gibt aber dies
hat vor allem mit einer total verfehlten
qualifikation und bildungspolitik zu tun
bei viel ist da der zug einfach
abgefahren die wahrheit ist dass es
branchen gibt in denen es fast unmöglich
ist arbeitskräfte zu finden und ist eben
das schon fast klischeehafte beispiel
welches gerade der russischen regenten
erfüllen europäische unternehmen suchen
verzweifelt nach programmierern
informatikern und spezialisten für
cybersicherheit nach arbeitskräften
welche die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
europäischen unternehmen gegenüber ihren
konkurrenten in amerika und asien
erhöhen mit der migration der russischen
fachkräfte nach europa könnte also zwei
fliegen mit einer klappe schlagen
erstens schwächen sie russland das ohne
seine besten fachkräfte immer stärker
zurückfallen und zu einem noch
schnelleren demografische
wirtschaftlichen untergang verdammt wird
und zweitens hätten sie den europäischen
staaten etwas legerer zu werden und die
renten ihrer alternden bevölkerung zu
zahlen die frage ist also warum lädt ist
europa bisher ab seine tore für
russische auswanderer sperrangelweit zu
öffnen genau dieser frage gehen wir
jetzt auf den grund
[Musik]
fast food ihn aber liebt die hose
fast alle entwickelten staaten haben
spezielle einwanderungs programme um
talente und investitionen das heißt die
produktivitäts faktoren arbeit und geld
anzuziehen und unabhängig davon was man
von ausländischen arbeitskräften hält
zweifelt niemand daran dass es eine gute
idee ist mehr talente und mehr geld zu
bekommen deswegen gibt es in den usa zb
das berühmte bondi visum durch welches
tausende von menschen ins silicon valley
gekommen sind um den dortigen big tech
giganten erst so richtig bei ihrem welt
eroberungsfeldzug zu helfen auch mit
ihrer hilfe sind diese zu den herrschern
der welt geworden allein die
marktkapitalisierung von apple ist fast
doppelt so hoch wie die aller deutschen
dax unternehmen zusammengenommen und
täuscht euch nicht hinter dieser
gigantischen marktkapitalisierung steckt
nicht nur reine spekulation sondern
exorbitante profite auch titel von denen
europäische unternehmen nicht einmal
träumen können wetters fähigkeit und
profitabilität hängen hier direkt
zusammen natürlich versucht auch europa
talente und geld anzulocken aber im
vergleich mit den usa muten diese
bemühungen er als amateur oder gar
lachhaft an in diese rubrik können wir
auch all die goldenen dieser einordnen
mit denen russische oligarchen nach
london grad oder andere orte wie man bea
in spanien gelockt worden nein liebe
politiker welteroberung geht anders gut
die europäischen politiker sind von
putin und seine kollegen jetzt ganz ganz
bitter enttäuscht konnte doch wirklich
keiner wissen zu was sie fähig sind nein
wirklich keiner erinnert uns das nicht
an etwas gerade in deutschland wo auch
schon mal keiner von was gewusst haben
wollte nun ja plötzlich werden die bösen
russen mit sanktionen belegt perfekt
europa will keine russischen oligarchen
mehr die mit putin in verbindung stehen
aber was ist mit den fachkräften was ist
mit den russischen informatiker der 30
jahre alt ist und keine verbindung zu
putin oder seiner reagiert nun hat was
hat dieser damit zu tun warum werden ihm
steine in den weg gelegt aber gut wie
sieht es denn auf der unternehmensseite
aus wollen die europäischen firmen
russin überhaupt einstellen die antwort
lautet ja
[Musik]
und ich gebe euch dass so ein weiteres
beispiel bei denen ich wieder aus
datenschutzgründen keine namen nennen da
ist stellt euch ein multinationales
unternehmen aus der lebensmittelbranche
vor dass überall auf der welt
niederlassungen hat nennen wir dieses
unternehmen der einfachheit halber malek
nun etwa hat gerade seine büros in
moskau auf grund von sanktionen
beschlossen fc barcelona will jedoch den
großteil der mitarbeiter von acme moskau
einstellen diese mitarbeiter haben sehr
nützliche fähigkeitsprofil welche die
firma unbedingt halten möchte und hier
kommt das problem die mitarbeiter von
acme moskau blitzen beim spanischen
konsulat in russland ab tut uns leid wir
können hier wieso nicht bearbeiten da
sie ihre berufserfahrung nicht
nachweisen können und warum weil etwa
moskau nicht mehr existiert glaubt mir
ganz ähnliche beispiele gibt es auch aus
deutschland mit anderen worten da diese
menschen für eine liquidierte firma
gearbeitet haben ist es unmöglich ihren
antrag auf aufenthalts und
arbeitserlaubnis zu bearbeiten
[Musik]
die beste möglichkeit legal von
außerhalb der eu nach spanien eis so
waren dann ist das so genannte
investmentgesetz das 2014 verabschiedet
wurde fast alle europäischen länder
haben ähnliche gesetze es wird salopp
auch als goldenes diesen bezeichnet im
falle spaniens ermöglicht dieses gesetz
auf zwei verschiedene arten an ein
offenes erlaubnis zu kommen
indem man großes um geld in spanien
investiert oder als sogenannte high
level professional so weit so gut der
teufel steckt jedoch wie so oft im
detail denn wie definiert das gesetz was
eine hochrangige fachkraft ist ganz
einfach es handelt sich um eine
fachkraft mit einem so spezialisierten
profil es ist fast unmöglich sein muss
dafür eine einheimische person
einzustellen dazu muss man natürlich
auch einen hochschulabschluss und
berufserfahrung vorweisen können das
problem dabei russische universitäten
sind nicht wie ihre europäischen
pendants akkreditiert und die
berufserfahrung eines russen aus einer
geschlossenen firma ist im moment
einfach nicht nachweisbar das ist so
simpel die fatale die europäischen
konsulate akzeptieren die lebensläufe
tausender russischer fachkräfte einfach
nicht sie stehen mit vollkommen leeren
händen da und das hat drei sehr
beunruhigende konsequenzen
[Musik]
die erste ist dass damit eine fatale
botschaft an die russen bisher mit wird
putin hat recht der besten hast jeden
einzelnen russen große phobie existiert
zweites europa eine riesen-chance
talente anzuziehen wenn sie gerade
massenhaft verfügbar sind und drittens
blamiert sich europa wieder mal als
unflexibel verschlafen star und nicht
zukunftstauglich denn es ist nun mal
nicht dasselbe russland mit dem wissen
zu verlassen dass deine einzigen
alternativen kasachstan oder indien sind
weißrussland mit dem wissen zu verlassen
dass sich in der europäischen union ein
viel besseres leben erwartet und die
zeit wird deutlich knapp das jetzige
opportunität fenster ist einzigartig und
es ist nur eine frage der zeit bis
russland seine grenzen schließt und
immer mehr zu einem nordkorea 20 notiert
wenn der kreml wird keine andere wahl
haben als allen seinen bürgern die
ausreise zu verbieten und es wäre
beileibe nicht das erste mal dass dies
geschieht
[Musik]
1922 schloss die damalige sowjetunion
ihre grenzen für alle ihre bürger 1961
errichtete der aus dem kreml gesteuerte
der staat auf deutschem boden eine mauer
in berlin um zu verhindern dass seine
bürger in den westen flüchten solch
drastische maßnahmen würden auch aus
einem anderen grund ergriffen werden
russland kann es sich nicht leisten noch
mehr talente zu verlieren und wer jetzt
noch daran zweifelt dass putin russland
in einem absolut totalitären und
faschistoiden staat verwandelt braucht
sich nur den am dritten april 2022 oder
staatlichen russischen
nachrichtenagentur ria nowosti
veröffentlichten artikel zur lösung der
ukraine frage durchzulesen just am
gleichen tag an dem das massaker von
butscher ans licht der
weltöffentlichkeit kam der ria nowosti
autokino face herr gates hat mit seinem
leitartikel putins lupenreines
völkermord manifest verfasst und
späteren glasklar was ein meister mit
entnazifizierung der ukraine wirklich
gemeint hat die physische vernichtung
der ukraine als start und kulturelle
entität mitsamt der ermordung all jener
menschen die mit diesem ziel nicht
einverstanden sind sergej greift die
worte postings auch erklärt dass die
ukrainische elite liquidiert werden
müsse da ihre umerziehung unmöglich sein
und da ein erheblicher teil der massen
passive nazis und komplizen seien somit
sei auch die bestrafung des ukrainischen
volkes durch russland gerechtfertigt wie
war das nochmal mit diesen europäischen
gutmenschen die den ukrainern zur
kapitulation beraten haben um sich zu
retten und menschenleben zu schonen und
diesen unangenehmen krieg so schnell es
geht zu beenden welche meinung habt ihr
über diese menschen angesichts all
dessen was jetzt ans licht gekommen ist
nun ja wir haben ja bereits in einem
früheren video vorausgesagt dass es nur
eine frage der zeit ist bis sie kommt
diese vom kreml in auftrag gegeben eine
rhetorische lizenz zum töten welche
besagt dass die russen alle die ihn zu
ukraine sport kommen zum wohle der sache
einfach eliminieren dürfen es handle
sich um eine weitere krasse
eskalationsstufe des kreml in richtung
faschismus und es ist nur eine frage der
seit wann protein diese methoden auch
gegen die eigene die russische
bevölkerung zum einsatz bringt
[Musik]
dann wird sich wieder ein geistiger
brandstifter dies hinsetzen und erklären
was genau putin mit dem ausspucken des
ungeziefers aus dem mund des russischen
volkes gemeint hat es dürfte nun allen
klar sein dass selbst wenn die ukraine
die russischen besatzer aus ihrem land
vertrieben hat und damit für sie das
schlimmste vorbei sein sollte dann dem
russischen volk das wahre grauen erst
noch bevorsteht durch die gezielte
rhetorische entmenschlichung die
gleichsetzung aline russen mit
ungeziefer die auch noch ansatzweise
verdächtig sein könnten nicht absolut
pro putin zu sein hat der despot bereits
die psychologischen grundlagen zu ihrer
totalen entrechtung und schließlich
ermordung gelegt oder es ist wahrlich
erschreckend wie viele europäische
intellektuelle nun behaupten sie haben
dies nicht kommen sehen deswegen werden
die freiheit gegen den russen unsere
hilfe und aufnahmebereitschaft brauchen
sie werden nicht weniger gründe zum
flüchten haben als derzeit die
ukrainischen kriegsflüchtlinge
[Musik]
aber jetzt ist die frage erst mal an
euch gerichtet fällt euch einen grund
ein warum europa russische arbeitskräfte
nicht aufnehmen sollte wird europa
wirklich jemals seine türen für
vertriebene russisch talente öffnen
sollte es auch aus humanitären gründen
an die aufnahme russischer flüchtlinge
denken welche folgen könnte das für
europa und den krieg in der ukraine
haben wir immer sind auf eure beiträge
und diskussionen zu diesem wichtigen
thema schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video trotz des düsteren
themas gefallen hat und dabei vielleicht
auch etwas gelernt habt fast gibt uns
mit einem like teils mit freunden
unvergessliches abo mit glöckchen um
keines unserer videos zu verpassen
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine spende von euch mittels hält
dieses projekt weiterzuführen den peter
link dazu findet ihr eine beschreibung
unter dem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]